as significant as 1989 when the berlin
wall came down overwhelmingly the story
of 2012 is centered in the Middle East
hi I'm Matt Wells for recent TV and I'm
joined today by arch puddington he's the
vice president for research at Freedom
House Freedom House is a great
organization that every year publishes
the freedom of the world index been
doing that since 1972 the 2012 index is
freshly out tell us a little bit about
the kind of headline findings of that in
this very tumultuous a year that we've
lived in through 2011 overwhelmingly the
story of 2012 is centered in the Middle
East as significant as 1989 when the
berlin wall came down people were
inspired by events in in egypt they
started demanding their rights and the
leadership pushed back and you had
arrest killings detentions eggs eiling's
the usual chromic events that you see in
dictatorships i've used the Freedom
House over the years and and you're
right and talking about 1989 as being
this transformational year give us a
little bit of the historical sweep of
that how does the planet look compared
to 1972 in 1972 freedom was restricted
pretty much to Western Europe North
America and a few English language
speaking countries scattered around the
world and that was pretty much the
extent of political freedom and the rest
of the world was either partly free or
not free there was very little freedom
then by the year 2000 that had
completely changed most of the world was
democratic most much of the world was
free and the dictatorships had shrunk
rather considerably tell us a little bit
about the origins of Freedom House the
index came out in 1972 who started it
who funded it how much is the CIA
involved that's what everyone always
asks me what did what's the his
three and kind of purpose of freedom
well Freedom House was started in
nineteen forty one at a time when
Roosevelt wanted an organization of
eminent Americans that would move the
country away from isolationism basically
we were a non-governmental organization
set up to help guide the country towards
involvement in that war we've never
gotten money from the CIA plenty of
journalists have looked into that they
found all kinds of organizations that
were funded by the CIA but not freedom
and in one of the press release
documents for the new report there's
this note about immigration in Western
Europe and in North America in the face
of the most serious economic crisis
these countries remained unwilling or
unable to develop effective policy to
ensure assimilation and fair treatment
of immigrants things getting worse in
the developed West in terms of treatment
towards I I think they are getting worse
you have a now you have a kind of a twin
phenomena first you have the hostility
to immigrants especially from the Muslim
world and you're starting to see laws
being passed in countries like Belgium
and France that criminalize wearing
headscarves and Birkins and that sort of
thing they like to have them there to do
the work but they don't really regard
them as French or is German there were
stains or or whatever give us a
something to be happy about as we look
into 2012 what's a country that's moving
forward maybe off of the radar screen
tunisia i would say is the number one
positive story of the past year and
certainly of the Arab Spring and it's
potentially a model and it's shown a
kind of intelligent pragmatism as
opposed to vengeance seeking and its
attitude towards the old elite how is
the United States trending right now on
the things that you measure aside from
immigration the reaction to the walls
the Occupy Wall Street movement there
was a little harsh police tactics and we
actually deducted a point from the
American score because of that but I
would say that the condition of the ship
of state is wobbly sometimes these
things are not reflected in in our
scores but the problems that we see
can't necessarily be measured in freedom
in the world but they're obviously of
concern well we can all wobble forward
together arch puddington free house
thank you very much for recent TV I'm
Matt Welch